[موسيقى]
إنها آخر
حدود غير مستكشفة على الأرض لا
نعرف سوى القليل جدًا عن هذه
المنطقة
التي نسميها منطقة الهدل وهي
تلك المنطقة من المحيط التي تقل عن
6000 متر أو 20000 قدم
لا يمكنك الوصول إليها في غواصة عادية
ما نوع المركبة التي
تحتاجها لتحمل الضغوط
هناك سؤال مثير للاهتمام للغاية
لأن الضغط
نسبي تمامًا عندما تصعد مركبة فضائية
إلى الفضاء ،
فهم لا يواجهون سوى
تغيير في ضغط جو واحد
بين داخل المركبة الفضائية
وخارجها.
نتعامل مع فرق ضغط
يبلغ حوالي 1100 ضغط جوي ،
لذا فإننا نغوص في كرة تيتانيوم
قادرة على تحمل
100000 طن من الضغط ، يستغرق الأمر حوالي
أربع ساعات ونصف للوصول إلى
أعمق نقطة في محيط العالم
نذهب إلى أسفل عبر  الماء بسرعة حوالي
ستة أقدام في
الثانية وعادنا أطلقنا ثقل الصابورة
في الأسفل لأه لمجرد أن
نخرجنا من القاع ونتجه
نحو السطح وهكذا يكون الأمر على وشك
ثلاث ساعات ونصف الساعة عائدين إلى المنزل ،
ما تراه عندما تصل إلى
قاع المحيط في أعمق جزء منه ،
هذا هو الجزء الأكثر روعة مما
نفعله ، إنه استكشاف حقيقي
أنت تعلم أننا لا نعرف أبدًا ما الذي سنقوم
به  نرى أن كل غوص قد أسفر عن شيء
رائع في
كثير من الأحيان شيئًا جديدًا للعلم
نشاهده لأول مرة
نكتشف مناظر طبيعية كاملة لم
تكن معروفة من قبل
ولا تزال يومًا كاملاً في وقت السفر ،
لذا كم من الوقت
يمنحك ذلك في قاع المحيط
نحاول البقاء في الأسفل لمدة ثلاث إلى خمس
ساعات في الأسفل ،
فأنت تعلم أنه استثمار كبير
للوقت والطاقة يتطلب الأمر من الفريق بأكمله
لإعداد هذه السيارة وإنزالها
، ولذا نحاول استخدام كل دقيقة
ممكنة في الجزء
السفلي  تحتوي الغواصة على ثلاثة منافذ عرض ، واحد
لكل من
الركاب ، ولكن يوجد أيضًا منفذ مركزي واحد
يسمح لنا برؤية قاع البحر
ولكننا محاطون أيضًا
بكاميرات عالية الدقة مرتبطة جميعًا
إلى شاشة
أمامنا ويمكننا النظر في أي اتجاه
بالخارج وهذا أمر مهم لأننا لا
نعرف حقًا إلى أين نحن ذاهبون ، فنحن
دائمًا تقريبًا أول البشر الذين ذهبوا إلى
هناك على الإطلاق
وهكذا على الرغم من أن لدينا
خريطة ثلاثية الأبعاد
صنعناها في اليوم السابق ، نحتاج إلى رؤية جيدة جدًا في
الخارج لمعرفة ما هو قادم
تعرفه بالنسبة للبشر ، لا نخشى حقًا
ما لا يمكننا
الشعور به وهكذا عندما تكون في
طائرة وأنت
لا تفكر بشكل طبيعي في مرور الرياح
بسرعة 500 ميل في الساعة وهي
سالب 50 هناك وليس هناك
ما يكفي من الهواء لاستنشاقك فقط إذا كان
بإمكاني رؤية بلدة أو يمكنني رؤية شاحنة
ونفس الشيء  في الشمس ، لا يوجد
إحساس بالحركة ، لا يوجد
إحساس بصوت
لا يمكنك سماعه أو الشعور بأي شيء من
الخارج ، إنها مجرد رحلة استرخاء هادئة للغاية
إلى المجهول ،
وأعتقد أننا نعرف القليل جدًا
عن المحيط لدرجة أننا بالكاد نفهم ما هي
الأسئلة التي يجب طرحها.  نسأل
ناهيك عن القدرة على الفهم
الإجابات ، دوري ودور الفريق
الذي أعمل معه
هو ببساطة فتح الباب ، فهذه هي
أول مركبة
في كل تاريخ البشرية لديها
القدرة على الوصول إلى أعماق المحيط
أه في أي محيط وفي أي عمق وفي أي وقت
إنها تشبه إلى حد كبير الأخوين رايت
مع أول آلة طيران ،
هذه مجرد خطوات الطفل الأولى